date le ragazze venute questo nuovissimo
video oggi proviamo a vedere se può
giocare un workshop perché da un sacco
di tempo che non faccio una partita
workshop e ne ho scaricato un po anche
l'altra volta hanno già scaricato un
sacco ricordate quella del labirinto
posso provare a fare escape game ci
siamo 0 gusto e perfetto che allora
regole osserva esplora usa il tuo
cervello per arrivare alla fine questa
21 quindi qui io non posso farlo sta ben
due bei ragazzi allora partiamo allora
qua devo mettere 50 50 per aprire la
porta molto semplice però almeno abbiamo
capito come fu detto ma un altro gioco
c'entra marzo nel bureau che trig prove
l'edgar usiamo il mio cervello bello
andare avanti quindi non staremo fermi
allora io a fare qualcosa si può passare
di qua no perché bloccato lo storage
porto devo invitare un oggetto sicuro o
hamisk il rum e avrete un escape room
sta roba ufficio la patrona 4 fatto
preme qual volta ho fatto verso gioco
c'è veramente bellissimo
ancora al 50 50 non penso valga più
stavolta esatto jonathan cori elvgren
yen dai cori jonathan che vediamo da
jonathan no questo quindi 57 ma questo è
il 75 74
2077 video purtroppo hanno il passo non
c'entra niente
57 43 sarà quello allora 57 43 credo sia
questo
eccolo lì proprio lui tutto qua la una
batteria
ho trovato una batteria vabbè allora
posto ho finito ho trovato una batteria
bene almeno siamo abbiamo fatto un
progresso uno solo probability room la
stanza dell'abilità il 7 batterie to
unlock abilities va bene e cosa mi dà le
abilità pian piano cos'è sono una
scatola cosa vuol dire sono una scatola
non so perché tu dovresti vedere una
macchina qua non c'è nessuna macchina ok
a cosa ma cosa è la succede
cos'è sta roba a cagare è un 9 quello
dai è fatta per persone con un quoziente
intellettivo st mappa e lo pensavo anche
perché non ce l'ho quindi molto
divertente sta roba
ma veramente figo veramente non avrei
mai immaginato sta cosa siamo a livelli
proprio di la teoria matematica di
euclide con cui non si riescono non
riesco neanche ad arrivare sopra le
scatole per prendere quella batterica
figura possa saltare normale va bene
ma c'è un passaggio bellissimo ma chi
aveva visto che il passaggio sul muro e
che ne so va bene adattato abbia mai
perché non sa proprio uscire e roero ero
in un punto imprecisato
ho visto c'è un buco nel muro bene
abbiamo fatto a vado a prendere l'altra
che l'altro camuffamento io ho preso
adesso i muscoli posso se posso usare
qualcosa di soldi ne fosse vero
bell'inizio
va bene e cosa me ne faccio di sta roba
scusate se posso chiedere a ok non ho
capito cosa invece cosa me ne posso fare
posso andare a togliere le scatole di
qua levatemi dalle scatole scatola euro
che è posto e poi per questa novità
essere la torta ma potevo anche farne a
meno posso darle come scale per aveva
arriva da qualche parte casa inter coach
è un altro codice che è strano perché
ancora non era successo ma ai boys siamo
arrivati al punto in cui io ho spremuto
tutto il tutto quello che potevo
spremere il mio cervello purtroppo non
ne sono venuto a capo perché
allora vi faccio vedere a me non mi
piace mai dato internet soluzione quindi
se non lo trovo non lo trovo non sono in
grado e amen
abbiamo come si dice due cose esperti
sacco quindi se non ci arrivo non ci
arrivo dire che io possa arrivare fino
qua sempre forse i limiti in a vita
abbiamo vedere col mouse
comunque la sa che sta league ora
fissatevi in testa questa va anzi
giampiero mettilo mi sovraimpressioni in
basso a destra ok ok
intanto lo ricordo a memoria lo visita
me tante volte lo so allora lo vedete in
basso adesso che sono esattamente sicuro
perché ci sono anche i numeri di sotto e
quella lei la macchina è anche gialla
come cosa giallo che vedete lì quindi
quella dove va messo il codice allora
sono la sta qua e segna esattamente il 2
quindi primo numero è il 2 e fino qua la
seconda è la bailey che sta esattamente
qua ed è il
3 esattamente tre perché l'aic sta
esattamente in questo punto in questo
paletto che la cei che sta in mezzo il
mezzo preciso lo vedete il mezzo è
questo qua 1 ok a parte che non c'è
un'altra neanche a volerla quindi per
forza questo è uno perché ci sono quello
2 3 1 e poi c'è l'ultimo della di che è
il 9 proprio come segnato quindi 23 19
cioè che schizzano anche due addirittura
parole mentre se io vado a mettere 23 19
nella macchina che questa guardi ci
piove che questa vedeva quale deve
essere dietro onore non funziona
spettante proprio c'è scritto 23
gasperino non va quindi c'è o c'è
qualcos'altro che non sto capendo però
vi giuro sono a due ore di registrazione
quindi 929 quasi e quindi non credo di
poter arrivare a questo questo è il
limite del cervello del pari forse i
propri limiti assenza proprio non va
vista dall'altra firma è visto a vista
dalla parte opposta tipo di quale
speculare può essere parte no ma non ci
sono anche i numeri quindi non vedo
perchè non ci sono neanche i numeri non
è possibile non c'è neanche il numero
sulla sulla colonna qui niente ci
abbiamo provato 239 ragazzi non funziona
ci sono le scalette vi disegnate ma non
ho capito cosa voglia dire ho provato a
fare anche i giri per vedere se ci sono
sosta al piano di sopra se c'è roba ma
non ne vedo mezza ve lo giuro anche
sulle altre colonne non si vedono numeri
quindi non riesco proprio a capire dove
potrebbero essere quei numeri li di
giorno che ho fatto tutto è il piano tre
volte non c'è stato verso di trovare i
numeri a tutti quindi niente ragazzi non
posso più andare avanti
avevo scoperto nel mentre anche che si
possono lanciare i maialini
ma le casse con i maialini là dentro
però effettivamente non trovata una sola
le altre si troveranno più avanti ma non
riesco ad arrivare piatti purtroppo
ragazzi non guardava doveva riguardare
sud arrivo fino qua peccato perché fino
guerra molto figo era molto carina
peccato che il mio cervello mimì crearmi
di creare i limiti ragazzo però se mi
date la soluzione magari le prossime
volte posso provare a vedere se a fare
controller e quiet quella la porta
finale secondo me belli sicure veramente
fatto bene veramente bello ho apprezzato
peccato per il mio poco intelletto
stanno facendo cadendo nove ragazzi
tenute nel cielo guardano questo va bè
ragazzi sprono vi sia piaciuto mi
dispiace non aver concluso però vi giuro
che ho provato di tutto questo era il
mio massimo lo skate e nei commenti nola
sono andato a vederla
scrivete secondo voi quale può essere io
posso provare ad andare a farla ad
andare a far la si può dire che se non
sapresti di scrivere henry ci vediamo
come sempre un tocco intelligente di
questo perché qua del letto hanno visto
proprio poco da ragazzi
[Musica]